la communauté Emmaüs de Touraine qui
organisait sa grande vente de printemps
le week-end dernier samedi et dimanche
les plus belles pièces récupérées au fil
des mois par les compagnons étaient mis
en vente retour sur le lancement de
cette grande braderie c'était samedi
matin et il y avait full Faustine
les clients patientent 10 heures sonnent
et c'est la ruée vers les bonnes
affaires rayon vaisselle brocantes et
antiquités il faut aller vite il faut
être dans les premiers lave-vaisselle
les objets
usuels mais anciens vous avez trouvé
votre bonheur
pour l'instant pour cette grande vente
les compagnons ont préparé et remis en
état des milliers d'objets meubles et
vêtements les rayons sont quatre fois
plus remplis que d'habitude une aubaine
pour les clients des collants Christian
Dior
et des chaussures mais des chaussures
maintenant les chaussures de petite
vieille
parce que vous avez des choses un peu
plus élaborées voilà et de la meilleure
qualité voilà c'est un peu plus il y a
plus de choix dans les rayons des
clients réguliers et d'autres qui
viennent d'exceptionnellement pour cette
grande vente pour tous Emmaüs est un
remède anti-inflation et certains
n'oublient pas que les ventes viennent
également soutenir la communauté c'est
aussi une démarche humaniste je pense
c'est important pour vous ça très très
important parce qu'il y a énormément de
misère et je crois que
on dort un petit peu trop Régis et le
spécialiste des meubles compagnons
depuis trois ans à Esvres il a travaillé
dur pour proposer des articles de
qualité la grande vente est une fierté
ça nous permet de sortir un peu de notre
cachette et de nous mettre en valeur une
chance donc j'essaie de m'exprimer dans
mon métier donc là je suis très content
durant cette grande vente 80% des biens
partiront l'argent récolté servira à
soutenir Emmaüs et d'autres associations
partenaires Emmaüs qui ne touche pas de
subventions de l'État